are you struggling to get views on
youtube do you
feel like sometimes youtube is like this
rubik's cube well i'm excited for
today's
video because we're going to be diving
into three c's of why you might be stuck
on youtube and if we're just meeting my
name is heather torres and i
am part of a team of creators here at
think media where our passion
is to help you build your influence with
online
video and we uh do this here on the
think marketing
show as well as on our podcast and over
on think media and we have a course
called video ranking academy that's
helped
thousands of students learn how to solve
this cube right well not this cube
particularly but definitely
solve youtube and we're on a mission to
help
10 000 purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you create a full-time living doing
what they love
making an impact in the world with the
power of
video and i'm excited because we're
going to be going through
how to get views like if you're not
getting views
this could be why but let me know in the
comments did you have a rubik's cube
growing up like is this something you
solved you know this
this is i think one of the hardest
things i've ever had to do
and i've never solved one before my
eight-year-old son though has figured
out
the algorithm of solving the rubik's
cube did you know
that in solving rubik's cubes it's
called an algorithm also well
we're gonna be breaking down how to do
this how do you solve it and
what steps do you need to take in order
to break through
to get discovered to get your message
out there in
the world and this is the think
marketing show so i'm going to do a
little bit of training and then you can
come on for
q a our team is in the comments right
now and they're dropping the link for
you if you want to join us
live for q a but let's go ahead and get
into
how do we solve this how do we break
through
and solve this and actually get views
because i know
that your message matters and i know
that if you're on youtube
you have a purpose to help people right
let me know in the comments what is your
channel about what's your youtube
channel focused on we're gonna jump
right into number one which the reason
why you might not be growing
is confusion the reason you might not be
growing on youtube is because
when you confuse you lose now
well what does this mean for youtube
maybe you've picked up a camera and you
started creating
maybe you started your youtube channel
and you're just not growing
well what this means is if you're not
clear
on who you serve and how you serve them
then how can someone find you you know i
believe that
when you get on youtube you really need
to define
yourself define your channel as a
channel
that is helpful and if you want to check
out here on the think marketing show
i actually did a training last week
where i talked about three different
types of channels and what channel we
recommend if
you want to get fast growth on youtube
and that is
an educational channel that is a channel
that helps people
solve a problem now i know that you are
purpose driven
i know that you want to help people and
i know that you have a vision for
freedom for your life
but if you don't know what you do then
how can other people know what you do
like let me know if you've ever been in
this situation maybe you know
thanksgiving's coming up
and you're sitting around the table and
it's like you know hey aunt lucy oh yeah
you know what do you do and you're like
um i have a youtube channel and
i like make these videos um and it's
kind of complicated
if those words are coming out of your
mouth
then you're confusing if you don't know
what your channel is about if you don't
know how you help people with that
channel
then how can someone find you now the
reason i say that is because we believe
here at think media that discovery
videos
being someone that is solving a problem
answering a specific question
to someone's problem that's what's going
to help you break through
on youtube and these are some questions
i want you to write
down who do you help
who do you help you need to define that
you need to really think about
who do i want to help now i understand
you might be like me and you've got big
vision
but there is a specific type or
category or demographic or tribe
that you're called to serve and so who
do you want to help
you know when i think about our channel
here at think media we are
called to serve creators just like you
we're called to serve purpose-driven
entrepreneurs who want to figure out
this youtube thing
to get their message out there to get
financial freedom
time freedom lifestyle freedom we know
that that's who you are so we make
content to serve you
and then the next question i want you to
write down is how do you help them
entrepreneurs are problem solvers who
get paid
right so if you're here on youtube if
you're creating a channel if you're
trying to reach an
audience how do you help them it makes
me think of nicole who's one of our
students in video ranking academy she
just passed
100 000 subscribers just had baby number
two this week i'm so excited for her but
nicole is a occupational therapist for
pediatrics she also is a parenting coach
and she really has a heart to serve
mother she has a heart to serve mothers
with toddlers and under
right how does she help them she helps
them with all things
that are related to uh that stage of
life she helps with things with tummy
time and with breastfeeding and with
feeding your child and for
playtime and for speech development and
and cognitive development
she really is helping serve her audience
so
who do you serve and how do you serve
them and the last one is what problem do
you solve
is there a definitive problem that you
help people with
you know we get here a lot i think uh
people say you know i wanna help people
like live their best life
i wanna i wanna like help people with
their lifestyle i wanna like help people
grow
that's not actually a specific problem
there's not very many people that wake
up one day and they're like you know
what i really want to work
on my my uh lifestyle
they're not typing that in here's what
they're typing in how do i get out of
debt
here's what they're typing in how do i
not argue with my spouse
here's what they're typing in how do i
go to college
here's what they're typing in how do i
eat a keto diet
here's what they're typing in how do i
get my kids to fall asleep
are you seeing what i'm saying what
specific
problem do you solve so if you're not
growing on youtube
there may be a confusion issue and you
need to get some clarity
i've got some tips for you coming up but
if you're getting value out of this
video go ahead and hit
the like button and share it with a
friend if you know someone who's trying
to grow on youtube right now
get them over to this video you can
share this video with a friend
here's some examples we have our think
media think media is our main channel
uh here at think and we help content
creators we help purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
with the tips and tools for building
their influence online
we do camera reviews microphone reviews
we go through
avls that's audio video lighting
stability
and then we teach you how to do youtube
we teach you the ins and outs of
the uh youtube studio and how to how to
get your videos seen we teach you how to
create videos we're all about
helping solve the problem of how do i
do youtube right that's what we help you
with
it makes me think of mary mary is one of
our success students you saw her she
just passed a hundred thousand
subscribers
so encouraged by mary and her uh path
that she's done here at think
and mary helps with traditional cooking
for the modern pioneer
now mary is not teaching you how to golf
mary is not teaching you
how to use your laptop mary is teaching
you how to make bread
without needing it you hear me so what
problem do you solve and who do you help
mary is saying right here she helps the
modern pioneer
so mary is helping a certain specific
type of person
who's interested in this type of cooking
right
what problem do you solve who do you
help right
and then uh this is one of my channels
the homeschool house i help
young mothers learn how to homeschool i
believe that there are different types
of
education available i know that there
are and i believe that you can have
freedom
in your educational choices and i want
to help mothers
see their options that they have i know
exactly who i serve
and i know exactly what i'm talking
about on that channel
caveat in homeschooling let's let's be
real
it makes me think of chris from fly ride
chris has a
custom lighting channel chris is now one
of our ten thousand he's gone full time
on youtube
with custom lighting he's helping the
car geek
figure out how to do all the cool
lighting things on their car he's made
an
entire channel around there it makes me
think of my friend justin from totaldog
he is a local based business but his
youtube channel
is all about dog training okay so who do
you serve
and how do you serve them you may not be
growing because you have a confusion
issue so here's what i need you to do
you're an action taker hashtag
action taker in the comments right now
you need to get clear
on your value proposition well what's a
value proposition
a value proposition means what value do
you bring to the table
how do you help people and if you want
more information about this
i have some uh tips at the very end that
are going to help you with that but
let's move on to number two number two
is consistency
you may not be growing on youtube
because you might not be posting
on youtube right when you want to grow
on youtube the key
is being consistent consistency
of posting videos will not only allow
your audience to know you're showing up
but it'll help you
level up as a creator let me know if
you've ever started something
right like i remember when i taught my
son how to swim
he was in there and he was like trying
and he was dressed you know
it was bad it was just bad but over time
as he learned more and more as he did
those exercises more and more in the
pool he got more comfortable
he got more confident and now he's like
a little fish in the water
right consistency matters and it makes
me think about
some of my favorite tv shows shout me
out in the comments let me know what are
some of your favorite tv shows now
no judging here okay i'm an eclectic
viewer of things on television netflix
now but remember way back like before
there was netflix it wasn't that long
ago when you actually had to like set
your dvr
to record it and you did dvr because you
didn't actually want to watch any of the
commercials
who who here is in the comments where
you remember pre tivo
like remember when tevo first came out
and you're like what
you can skip all of the commercials
what is happening remember those days
well here's some of my favorite channels
or
my favorite shows uh raise your hand if
you are a scandal fan
in here okay scandal olivia pope anyone
with her the
cutest outfits in the world yes okay uh
always on on thursday nights at nine
always on thursday nights at nine what
about this is us any this is us fans in
uh in the comments right now this is us
i mean can you watch a single episode of
this is us and not cry
i mean like the writers of this sh of
this series
they just know how to like pull on your
heartstrings
any this is us people well this is us
comes out on tuesday
at 9pm what about the amazing race any
amazing race fans in the audience i love
amazing race i
i want to go on amazing race at some
point this is one of our family
favorites it comes on wednesday at eight
so my kids always get to stay up late on
wednesdays
to be able to watch that one and then
what about idols any idol fans
in the audience yeah so idol sundays and
mondays
at eight why am i sharing with you
heather's favorite shows that come on
why am i sharing with you
the amount of television that i watch
well uh i'm sharing that with you
because
it matters that you're consistent
it matters that your audience knows when
you're showing up
right when you think about these
television shows they've
primed us to be ready for consistency
they've primed us as an audience that
when your audience is coming to youtube
they want you to show up so my question
to you is
how often are you showing up for your
audience you know when i think about
like
my relationship my husband and i we've
been married for almost 15 years three
kiddos
and when i think about what it takes to
create a marriage
it takes both people showing up
consistently for each other
now if one of us decided not to show up
for each other well it probably wouldn't
be a marriage right
but because we're both showing up
consistently and we both learn to
know like and trust each other
that's what allows for the relationship
to grow and the same thing is true here
on youtube
when you are creating content it needs
to be consistent
content meaning you should show up for
your audience
first rather than expecting views to
come in
rather than posting one video expecting
it to go viral and thinking why is no
one showing up for me
well i want to ask you are you showing
up for people
are you putting in the work are you
coming to the table with good content
that's going to be helpful and help
solve someone's problems
so why you might not be growing on
youtube one
you might not be posting on youtube but
two
you may not be posting consistently
so action taker you need to create a
posting
schedule your next step if you're not
being consistent right now is to commit
to yourself
first that you're gonna show up for you
that you're gonna take the time to
create the content not for other people
but for you first because i can tell you
as you grow on youtube
as you start to consistently get more
views as you start to grow
that channel and grow that audience
you're a leader my friend
which means that leaders need to show up
consistently
so your action step if this is what
you're struggling with right now for not
growing
is you need to create a content schedule
you need to create a posting schedule
here's what i need you to think about
youtube is your job
if you don't show up for work you don't
get paid right so the same thing goes
for youtube
you've got to be consistent when you are
on
youtube so number one maybe you're
lacking clarity maybe you're confusing
maybe you don't know what your channel
is about or you're not making content
that is consistent for that audience and
number two
is you may not actually be posting
consistently
on youtube let me know in the comments
if this is helping you
break the algorithm of
the rubik's cube right solving the
rubik's cube just like solving the
algorithm
of youtube and number three number three
lean in because this is a big one
and this is probably one not talked
about enough in the space of youtube
it's definitely talked about an online
business but i can tell you is you step
out of your comfort zone and you start
to step into this new world of youtube
this is probably something holding you
back comparison
comparison comparison might be holding
you back
let me know i mean let's let's be real
here it it's sometimes
hard seeing other people succeed when
you're trying to do the same thing
they're doing
and you're not seeing the same traction
let's be real it can be hard
when you're putting in the work and
you're putting in the hours and you're
putting in
all of this energy and you're not
getting the views and she is
comparison is the thief of joy
my friend if you've stepped into this
space if you've
raised your hand and said i want to be a
leader i want to help i want to serve
i want to be someone that's making a
difference in other people's life and
impacting the world in positive ways if
you've raised your hand
and you've decided to do this youtube
thing then you've
got to let go of the comparison that can
come along with it
that is a personal thing that rather
than
championing others rather than looking
at someone else doing something and
saying
if they can do that i can do it too
rather than turning it around and saying
well why can't i do that
how come she can do that why am i not
growing how come she's growing right
when you start to bring
that negative energy into what you're
doing
you're doomed to fail i'm here to be
your coach i'm here to tell you
it's straight really you've got to let
go of the comparison
that happens and i love this quote that
comes uh
this quote from donald miller i'm sorry
from john akoff john acoff says
don't compare your beginning to someone
else's middle
i remember when we first started here on
youtube and i say we
sean cannell had already built a
successful channel to 16 000 subscribers
he had
gone full time uh him and his wife sonia
on youtube
by affiliate marketing and when i
stepped on the scene and came into the
world of think we were at 16 000
subscribers
and i remember as i started to grow in
what we were doing here at think media
and getting
on camera and starting to teach and
starting to to really share
some of the things that i'm truly
passionate about which is online
marketing which is
family freedom which is the idea that
you can create this without having to
have a large audience
man i sure remember looking at other
people who were steps ahead and thinking
i'm not i'm not as good as them who am i
i dropped out of marketing school and
i'm teaching marketing who am i to be
doing this
right when i started comparing my
beginning
to someone else's middle i started to
lack confidence
and my friend if you're here and you're
listening to my voice right now you've
got it in you
you can do this youtube thing you just
need to
stop comparing your beginning
to someone else's middle here's what i
ask you to do
rather than comparing yourself champion
that person
wow look at that they got a viral video
wow look at that they got that new brand
deal man if they can do that i can do
that
they're pioneering the way they're
making it easier for me to be able to do
it because they're figuring it out first
i don't have to make the same mistakes
because there's people ahead of me that
are telling me right from
or telling me what's right what i should
do and what i shouldn't do
and one of the things that i i would
love for creators to start doing
is is stop the negative talk you know
when you think about as we're growing
we start to say these things to
ourselves this is a societal thing right
we start to say these things to
ourselves and i need you to know your
words that you say to yourself
matter they matter so deeply
and one of the things that we do is we
start to go into this
well i i'm not that great
i'm not an expert i'm i'm not someone
who
who uh i i'm i'm not them
i'm not educated i i'm not i'm not
someone who understands cameras
right we start saying these defeating
things to ourselves what about i can't
well i can't do that well i can't be her
i can't get a posting schedule going i
can't create great videos
what about i don't well i i don't know
how to do that
or well i don't have the resources i
don't have the time
right when we start saying these
negative things to ourselves
we are defeating what's trying to be
built
if you had this passion if you knew that
you were here to help if you knew you
were here to serve
you knew that you were here to build
something right gosh what a glorious
thing we get to build this thing
but if we're saying these defeating
words to ourselves
it could be why we're not growing if
we're going to be the thing standing in
the way
of the growth we've got to change the
way that we're speaking to ourselves
so here's what i need you to switch that
to i can
i can figure this out right
i i can grow i can learn
i can find a mentor i can listen to the
podcast i can read the books i can learn
just like they can
right what about i am how about
i am good enough to do this how about i
am smart how about i am
someone that has something to bring to
the table how about i am
confident are you saying these words to
yourself
are you giving yourself the grace and
the time to actually speak
life into yourself what about i will
how about i will figure this out man
youtube is hard man
figuring out how to do this thing is
hard
but you know how my eight-year-old
figured it out he can solve this thing
in a minute and 20 seconds you know how
he figured it out
youtube he watched some youtube videos
he watched some step by steps he saw
that there was an algorithm he saw oh
you got to do this one thing
and then this one thing and then five
more of these things
and then guess what he solved the
rubik's cube
same thing happens here on youtube you
will figure this out you
will build an influential channel you
will impact millions with your message
but you have to change the self talk if
you're getting value out of this video
today
make sure you hit that uh like button
and your action is to chase your own
vision
chase your own vision i spelled that
wrong
but you need to chase your own vision
and
what that means really is don't look at
what someone else
is doing keep your eyes on your own
paper right
if you know you're there to impact a
certain tribe if you know you're there
to impact certain people
then stay in your own lane your youtube
channel
is not going to be the same as theirs
their youtube channel i'm building
is not going to be the same as yours we
have different time limits we have
different uh
we have different resources we have
different experiences
we have different abilities we have
different gifts we have different
talents
friend your vision
is going to be yours so if you know that
you're supposed to build that
build it stick your eyes on your own
paper right go down your own path
and hear me your race your pace
it's going to look different so what
could be holding you back
from growing on youtube it could be
confusion in your
message it could be consistently
uploading videos
or it could be that you're comparing
what you're doing to other people
if you got value out of today's video
i'm super excited to
uh jump on with a few of you so make
sure you hit that like button
and i want to let you know about a free
class that we have coming up
we've got a free class that's going to
be happening on november
10th at 5 00 pm this is going to be a
free live
youtube class and sean cannell who is
the ceo and founder of think media is
going to be teaching you the three
secrets to success
on youtube this is updated information
if you've watched our previous master
class this is a brand
new class it's open to everyone it's
free for you to take this class
it's a one hour class you show up live
and then at the end of that class we're
going to share an opportunity with you
to go deeper with us here at think if
you're like
i'm raising my hand heather i need to
take this thing serious i'm ready to
step
up and actually do youtube then we're
going to give you that opportunity at
the end of the class but it's free
so make sure you sign up for it and i
have this short video for you to watch
and then i'm going to jump on with you
if you'd like to be a part of our q a
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel
do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for youtube
success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
i'm trying to sneak in that uh that
drink there real quick
hey we are here for the think marketing
q a
show so uh you can if you're just
jumping on right now
definitely uh you can watch the replay
of the quick training i just did
but if you'd like to jump on and get
your question answered with me
here on the show you can do that uh
there's a link being dropped and here's
what this looks like
if you're new to our q a shows here at
think media we love to see you
and talk to you and interact with you
and so what this looks like is you'll
click on that link you can
then come on live with me i've got let's
see i've got elba
in the waiting room right now and here's
a couple things you just want to make
sure that you're in a well-lit room
you don't want to be you know out
driving your car so if you're driving
right now just keep listening and just
join us on the next one
uh you want to make sure you've got
great audio because audio
and video matter and so we want to make
sure we can hear you
and see you uh when you come on and
ask your question and i'm excited
because we have elba
am i saying your name right it is elba
correct
awesome elbow welcome to the show
i'm so excited um ella tell the think
community
who you are what you do and let me know
your question
and so much responsibility at the same
time as you know
and well this question will be
uh you asked what was my question
um i've been
i think we're having a little uh trouble
with your audio we're having a little
trouble with your audio you've got your
microphone
speak into that one can you hear me
now i can yep okay i was
um
so i'm super excited about it and the
question will be how can i
like stay
how can i keep that
i think we're having a little bit of
trouble with your audio elba type in the
chat
real quick your uh your question i'll
make sure we get to elba's question
uh and make sure i was trying to figure
out if we could do her audio it was a
little muffled so definitely type that
out for me elba
really excited for your question um so
no worries type it out in our
chat area and i'm going to bring on
looks like we've got michelle
michelle is here on the show hi michelle
how are you
i'm good you know okay i can yeah it's a
little hot so just pull it away just a
little there you go
after elba i wasn't sure so i wanted to
back it away um
my question is i've been a part of vra
now since may
and it it has helped my channel grow
immensely i had like
25 subscribers when i started and i'm
nearing the 200 right now so i'm really
excited and
my niche is travel so it's kind of a
rough one right now
but things are starting to change i am
trying to figure out a way to monetize
this and make it into a business
and setting up an email list is
very high on my priorities and i want to
figure out
what is what would be a valuable lead
magnet
in travel and i'm trying to figure out
the best way to kind of get
some real market info from
my potential customers and what's the
best way to go about that
really great well michelle thank you so
much for being a part of the video
ranking academy community
i love hearing uh all of the things that
you're doing and you're right
travel has been kind of a hard one right
now but there's obviously
room for pivoting here's the thing
people are actually still traveling
so i know a lot of times we can put in
our mindset that uh no one's traveling
like we say like these big words of like
no one's doing it so i want you to know
that people
are still traveling and people are
searching right now um there's still
there's great deals that are happening
right now so
here's a couple things to think about uh
your question was about creating
a lead magnet what that is if you're new
to the think media community is
it means a way for you to share a free
gift with your audience to pull them off
of youtube and more into your world
which is what michelle's going to be
doing
so here's a couple things you want to
think about whether it's travel whether
it's homeschool whether it's tech no
matter what it is here's a couple things
to think about
you want to save people time money
and stress or overwhelm those are the
three
like big things you want to solve when
you're creating a lead magnet so
am i helping them solve time right can i
help them book things faster can i help
can i
uh the the 10 best things to do you know
in a certain area
the four airline hacks you need to know
like
these are the type of things time right
the next one is
money so especially with travel this is
a
huge opportunity and especially right
now
so thinking about ways you can save
people money like
how do i find the best deals where i
need to go are there four things i need
to know
what are the mistakes most people make
when they're booking an international
thing like
think about where someone is when
they're doing something the first time
so that's one that's another one and
then overwhelm so here's a couple things
about
overwhelm you think about packing you
think about traveling with children
you think about large groups uh travel
you you know like
thinking about the overwhelm that comes
with the experience of traveling
so you want to maybe think in those
different categories
and what's great about league magnet
lead magnets is you can create
multiple different ones to figure out
which one works
best and i love how you said you've been
trying to like get some audience
feedback on what they're looking for
i want to challenge you to go and join
like
four groups today on facebook and start
talking to people
like hey what is your biggest struggle
when it comes to traveling this is a
huge like
asking anyone what's your biggest
struggle when
they'll tell you people know what their
struggles are and then you can start to
think about what can i do to help them
with that
what are some travel resources people
need like what are the four
things people need in whenever they go
traveling what are the
right like thinking about those
different things um
that's what's gonna help you figure out
the lead magnet and you're gonna start
with one
and it may work and it may not and
remembering that all marketing is
just testing it's testing to make sure
that the marketing
and the message match so that you can
help them solve more problems does that
help you michelle
that helped a lot thank you hey uh let
people know where they can find you
if they have some travel questions
absolutely well my youtube channel is
the traveling cheesehead
and you can also find me on
instagram at travelingcheesehead
girl so it's spelled weird but
um same as you see on my thing the words
traveling cheesehead it's spelled weird
and then you can find me on twitter at t
cheesehead i love it thank you so much
for being on the show today
thank you bye i love what what she's
doing
if you saw right there just in that
short interaction michelle's really
thinking about her youtube channel like
a business
and that's what we want to teach you
here at think marketing it's really
about
understanding that you're in business
if you have a youtube channel you're in
business and she's trying to think of
ways
that she can serve her audience on a
deeper
level and you know we get questions all
the time like well shouldn't you keep
people on youtube and why do you want to
give get people off youtube
here's the thing people are going to
self-select if they want to go deeper in
relationship with you and
by offering what's called a lead magnet
or offering something that allows them
to go deeper in a relationship with you
that's a good thing it means that the
know like
and trust on your channel it means it's
working and that's what we want to see
if you're getting value-added today go
ahead and gently tap
the like button let's see if we can get
those likes up even more i've got
jason on today we're gonna bring jason
on
hey jason how you doing good
good hey let us know uh who you are
where you're watching from what your
channel is about and how we can help
um my name is jason gleason i live in uh
coldwater michigan
um actually i'm in my truck today um the
one
reason i'm asking i have a channel
that's pretty
niche um i raise show goats and stuff
like that
so i'm looking to ways to expand
other than what everybody else in the
show industry is doing um i've tried
different things i've reached out to
different people i use um for products
and i'm just trying to figure out how
can i move them
products um the products i'm getting
to make it look like i'm actually adding
value instead of just promoting myself
yeah really great you said show goats
like like
goats goats
yeah we raised boar goats which is a big
uh
meat industry animal yep yep okay i just
want to make sure i was hearing that
correct before i went on a whole tangent
of farm animals so
to make sure that that was correct um
what a cool niche that you're in
uh what an expertise to have so your
question is
how do you help promote products without
feeling like you're self-promoting is
that the question
yes great awesome well what's really
great about youtube is that
when you think about someone that wants
to join
into this tribe and it really is a tribe
when you think about
uh when you think about someone uh
wanting to step
into the arena of showing goats right
and being even in that field of what is
um a show like when you're thinking
about
what does someone need to know when
they're getting into this field
and when i think about like um i was in
uh
ffa uh future farmers of america shout
out to all the ffa peeps that are in the
in the crowd probably like two um but i
was in ffa
and man there was so much to learn when
i started
in horse judging is what i did i did
horse judging
and yes i'm a total nerd when it comes
to that
but when i got into that when someone
gets into anything this is for this is
for
anyone getting into anything they're the
beginner
is at such a learning curve to know what
they need
to know so when you're saying how do i
make content that's not
self-promoting or pushing products or
whatever that looks like i think one of
the things to think about is
are you um what is your motive in the
video
so when you think about my motive when
we're doing camera review videos
is not to like i'm not like let's sling
these cameras y'all
let's like let's make sure that you know
that everyone buys a camera
no our motive in the video is to help
educate
is to help people with the learning
curve is to help people
evaluate if it's the right purchase for
them
so when i think about how do i make
content that can help serve
that audience no matter what audience it
is and you're in an audience that is
very niche meaning like if you're
searching things on goats on youtube you
are super hyper niche
and that's great there's a whole
industry
around this and i know that it may feel
like sometimes like well what is this
you know what does this brush have to do
with anything or like what kind of feed
does the
does the goat need or like how do you
know if this is a good go and that's a
bad goat like all of these questions
that people have when they're coming
into this space
that's the content to make and how do
you then
provide affiliates with that is
you make sure that when you're creating
your videos that you're promoting a
product
or a service that you believe in and
that you've used and that you would
recommend
when i think about like when people get
into homeschooling the question i get
all the time is well what curriculum
should i get
right they want to know like what should
i buy tell me what to buy and they're
asking me that because they trust
my opinion just like they probably trust
your opinion jason
so when you think about when you're
creating content
that's going to serve that audience how
do you make content that it doesn't feel
self-promoting
that is of service i want you to be the
guide
i want you to be the best friend i want
you to be the mentor
when you're stepping into that space
when i started ffa
i read all the books about horses i was
like all about like
you know what do i how do i how do i
know if this is a a good quarter horse
or a bad quarter horse
what does this gelding look like like i
needed to learn all this terminology
what books can you recommend what
products do they need how do they like
what shed
should they have their uh goats in like
there's so many things
that are beyond just amazon that you can
be an affiliate for
so when you think about how you can
create content that can serve others
think about the products and the
services that you needed to learn about
when you got started
i hope that helps you out i know we have
some more people that are on today
uh let's go and see who we've got um
i'll bring on
uh kate uh i'm i'm gonna i hope i'm
saying this correctly i'm gonna bring
you one
okay well yeah okay okay well comedy but
that kathy is fine
hi kathy how are you hi i'm great i i
guess
i put my question up in the chat and
it's about what you say about chasing
too many rabbits
i have a channel for educational leaders
because i'm a principal
and um i've been an ap for a long while
and i wanted to
help other educational leaders like the
help i needed
but i've also been doing a show with my
brother just during quarantine
where we just had fun talking about pop
culture
and i'm enjoying that more but i'm not
quite sure who we
serve i mean you know it's keeping my
brother and i from being depressed and
missing each other since we're like 500
miles apart
but um yeah what
what what if you can't find that clear
definition
of who it is that uh that you serve
i love this really great question and
thank you so much just for being a part
of our community i know you've been a
part of our community and
what an amazing just testament to you
just sticking
at it over time and i'm just so
encouraged by you
being a creator i love this so much so
your question really is like
how do you figure out who you serve in
this new thing that you're doing right
right okay now let me ask you we want to
we want to think about
um uh what is the goal what is the end
goal
with this channel is this end goal to
like make this the thing that makes you
and your
brother not have to you know work
anymore and you guys are living off of
this and
is that the goal i think it is is it
okay
yeah okay i was gonna say or here's
something to think about
is it just a hobby i think a lot of
times in entrepreneurship we start to
think like
well i can only do that if i can make it
a business right like we start i do this
all the time
i'm like oh i'm gonna get into kayaking
i need to have a kayaking channel and
i could make money off of kayaking but
we also just need hobbies
like we also sometimes just maybe it's
just something you and your brother
do that's a side project that's fun to
do
now if it is the thing if you're like
nope heather this is the thing
i'm going to make this this is what we
want to do we want to start going for it
then this is where you start going into
more of the clarity
you start uh surveying your audience hey
who's watching let us know in the
comments how you found us
let me know in the comments like start
using your comment section
to start to curate who is watching your
stuff and i would assume that you're
probably making
these videos that are similar to other
people's videos right or are you going
like totally rogue somewhere else
well we're just doing we're live
streaming so we're not even really
making
videos to to to actually serve a purpose
so we tend to live stream we tend to
bring in guests
and like kind of feature them or or
you know feature a topic just all around
pop culture so it's it's
it is silliness but you know sometimes
it can be fun because
you know during all the um riots and
stuff we did shows about
pop culture and black and white so we
were able to have somebody in
and talk about race relations uh during
september's
uh hispanic heritage month we had uh
someone of puerto rican descent in
so we could actually kind of talk about
issues but still
keep it light and you know pop culture-y
fun kind of thing i love it i think it's
great i think when you think about
what you guys need to sit down and
define is a few things one uh you're
doing something together so this is just
my advice to you
whenever you start and you're creating
something there should be some type of
dividing lines and what that partnership
looks like who's in charge of what what
does that look like because
let me tell you more money more problems
i'll let you know that more money more
problems
right now it doesn't seem like a big
deal but it sounds like you might know
my brother
um yeah so just be thinking about what
does this partnership look like
right uh if this is the thing just this
where if this is the thing
and then i would say um you know start
creating content
that is trending which is what you said
you're doing so you want to be doing
trending content
there's a video that i want you to go
watch next which is over on think media
sean did it yesterday and it was if
you're under a thousand subscribers
watch
this it was all about this exact topic
for you so i definitely recommend that
that's the video that you watch
and then i would also study what um
what uh phil defranco is doing phil
defranco does an informational type show
kind of like what you're doing he
doesn't interview people
it's a different context but it's the
same
informational style it goes in that
bucket of information which is what
you're doing
um he does he he does his entire youtube
off of youtube ads and brand
sponsorships
so that would be how you would monetize
um this
type of content would be through brand
sponsorships that want to just get in
front of those types of people
that are consuming that type of content
there's nothing wrong with informational
content
but i would say your breakthrough is
going to be using
trending topics which is what you're
doing but it's really understanding
how to position that to be able to break
through in the market does that help you
it helps me a lot it does awesome i'm so
excited and encouraged by what you're
doing uh let me know in a couple months
how this partnership is going with your
brother okay
i will awesome thanks for being on today
thank you heather wow i love that now
that is just
uh that is in anything if you're
creating a youtube channel
with someone you should have some hard
conversations what does this look like
who's in charge of what roles and
and how does this look and and again her
question really was
you know about chasing those two rabbits
do i do both things um but she said this
is the thing so you've got to clearly
define
which channel if you're doing two
channels which one is the channel that
you're gonna do and
depending on what your answer is will be
dependent upon the advice that you get
i would suggest that you do a channel
that's going to
help you monetize quickly because you
need money for the mission friend
right so we want to monetize quickly but
i love what she's doing i love that
she's out there
working uh with her brother hey again
this uh video today is brought to you by
our think
master class if you've not registered
for our master class you can definitely
do that right after this video
go to thinkmasterclass.com we've got a
brand new live
free class coming up on november 10th at
5 00 p.m pacific standard time so you're
going to want to make sure you get
to that hey i want to get back to elba's
question uh elba was not at the very
beginning we were having some audio
issues
and so i want to make sure i get to her
question she says normally i've been
having 50 to 150
views on my video recently i got one at
600
views which she's super excited about
and her question is
how can i keep that momentum going
staying on that wave
uh on that video well here's my
suggestion to you elba
make a similar video so what we do here
at think media is if we've got a video
that's on fire
we make a part two right so we make a
part two of that video because
in youtube's algorithm suggested videos
get pulled when there's a part one and a
part two right like
it just is part of what that looks like
or create a
series of videos around that topic that
might be the topic
that's breaking through with your
audience so
on youtube you want to have a target
audience that you're reaching
and then you want to have some defining
buckets of the
topics that you talk about maybe three
to five topics
that you really go deep into and you're
gonna find that when you start talking
about those three to five
topics there's gonna be one or two of
those topics that people really
vibe with you on that's where the more
views are coming from that's where
they're like oh
i want more of that right so nicole who
i talked about at the beginning with uh
nicole with kids ot help she did a video
called tummy time for newborns
she did this video and it went viral it
got like a million views
and so she was like what do i do how do
i keep going what's next and i we were
like make another tummy time video
like what's the part two what else could
you talk about what's an updated
stat or research or something you could
bring to the table
to make a part two because if a person
is raising their hand
and saying i want that type of content
well let's give them more
of that type of content so i hope that
really helps you elba
we're really grateful for you elba's one
of our star
students here at think media and is just
crushing it with all that she's doing
i want to bring on uh let's see i've got
uh
vashna hi yeah it's actually vaishna
aishna hi how are you i'm good
good tell us where you're watching from
what your channel's about and how i can
help you today
yeah um my channel is called him made by
vaishna um i've actually come on
one other stream yeah and i believe tony
was the one who gave me the advice
so yeah i'm a arts college and lifestyle
youtuber
i'm kind of just starting out on like
very beginning stages and
um i just like i feel like the
niche that i've chosen like with
i mean like my art niche is like the
main nation like college and lifestyle
are
kind of like there's like the the
secondary niches
and i feel like college is doing really
well like
i have one video that has almost a
thousand views so that's like
for me that's a win but my art videos
are not doing well
because i feel like it's just like kind
of over saturated in that niche
so what's your question for me today my
question is
how can i um
rank in search and get found on my art
niche
in art in the art niche shari yeah
really really great question
now you're doing art and college advice
on the same channel yes
okay so uh so my advice actually is that
those
those two things while it's been working
up to this point to see what was working
better
um here's my next question to you which
one do you want to do
more of which one could you do for the
next three to five years
honestly um well i feel like college
will not apply in a few years because
like i'm gonna be graduating
so i feel like that's gonna leave that's
like just like a temporary niche that
i'm
kind of like you know just like hey but
like i feel like art is gonna
definitely stay awesome then we need to
go all in on art
so even though so here's what happens
sometimes on youtube is we're like oh
this one thing caught fire i should do
this one thing
right because we're like wow look i'm
getting the views i'm getting the vanity
numbers i'm getting the thing
but if that's not really the thing for
you and
art is going to be the thing for you
well we need to actually double down in
what's working
in art and so what type what type of art
are you doing
well i've done like a little bit of
painting but mostly i focus on greeting
cards
but when it comes to greeting cards like
i feel like when it comes to creativity
and greeting cards
there's like some like huge name brands
like five minute crafts and like some
really big names that really trend and
that
and i feel like like the those keywords
are so oversaturated it's been so hard
for me to get discovered
so just wondering like what can i do
about that
yeah yeah okay so a couple things you
can do um
and this is take this as you will
you can actually um double down on the
college stuff actually make money off of
the college stuff that will then
fund the art that you want to do that's
an option right you could be the art you
an artist is could just be what you are
but you're funding it through
the channel of the college stuff so that
could be a way
or you can double down on
what are people searching now i know
that there are that is it's saturated
just like beauty is saturated but it
doesn't
hold beauty people back from making
beauty content if this is what you're
called to do if this is what you're like
i'm gonna be an artist
come hell or high water i am going to be
an artist i'm going to break through on
youtube
you're going to figure it out and so
what you it's not maybe not in the first
10 videos maybe not in the first 30
videos
maybe in the first 100 videos you'll
have that one that breaks through
and you're like oh it's this random
thing when i do
watermelon greeting cards that everyone
loves like you don't know what it is
until you double down and you just start
creating so you've got to really decide
this is kind of a clarity piece for you
am i defining as an artist and i'm going
to just go all in and i'm going to find
the keywords i'm going to
do what five-minute crafts is doing i
would study big channels because
big channels are winning for a reason
right and i would
double down on what you're doing but i
would also get involved
in the community here's what five
minutes is not doing
they're not in crafting communities you
can
right there's a um a gal that they
interviewed on video influencers a while
ago
like maybe two years ago she did um
knitting she was a knitter and she's
like man the knitting
space is just huge but but she got
involved in the knitting community
she's created six figures off of courses
all about crafting and knitting
why because she found the audience and
she served them
well so i would be thinking um there's
other options too that you can do to
draw people to your channel
like making instagram reels right like
being on instagram making some instagram
reels and then having your youtube
videos
as the secondary piece but but building
that youtube channel because
youtube is a content library youtube is
going to be your portfolio youtube is
going to be where people can go and get
step-by-step tutorials right
but you can draw them in from instagram
so
those are just a couple quick tips i can
give you here today you've got to decide
though
if you're like i'm an artist that's what
i'm doing i'm going gonna i'm gonna make
this
happen then you're gonna find a way
because remember we're going back to
i can i am and i will and i want you to
write those down and i want you to know
that if someone else like five-minute
crafts can do this you can do it too
right like you've got it in you to do
this so i just want to encourage you
that
it may not feel like it's going to
happen overnight it won't
but if you just consistently commit to
making great content
you're going to have that video that
goes viral you're gonna have that thing
that that that one card company at
hallmark is like then calling you and
someone's like how did this all happen
and you're like bro i've been working on
this youtube channel for four years
that's how this happened right
like you don't even know the
possibilities that will happen
until you just stay committed and
focused to what you know your calling is
does that help you oh my god yes thank
you
thank you so grateful for you thank you
for being a part of the community are
you coming to
the live master class
yes i hopefully will be able to make it
awesome register for it
awesome thank you so much today wow well
hey
that's all the time we have for today's
class
this is not a class this was a q a like
what's happening today
so grateful for you to be here let me
know what your aha moment was
from today's q a and i want to remind
you we do have a free class that's
coming up on
november 10th at 5 p.m you can register
at thinkmasterclass.com and you can
check out this video for all of the
details
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel
do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video register today for this exclusive
training at
thinkmasterclass.com